I've got a five million person audience
in 24 months I looked at the actions we
took to try and reverse engineer why did
it happen so quickly I believe I boiled
it down to what I call the content unit
so content unit is the single most basic
piece of content so a jingle a single
image a tweet is in itself a Content
unit that is doing short form content
and long form content is simply how many
content units you stream together and a
Content unit has three parts hook gets
them interested retain keeps them
interested and then reward rewards them
for their time and attention and
encourages them to come back because
ideally you want your audience to watch
everything you have all the way through
and then have a reason to come back for
the next one